.
MORE OF OUR CONVERSATION WITH
WEST NOW.
>> THERE'S A GROUP MOB.
IT'S LIKE LIBERAL NAZIS WHO WILL
ATTACK YOU.
EVERYONE SAID AND IT WENT
TOWARDS YOUR FRIEND.
THIS GABBY GIRL AND GIGI AND
THEY WOULD'VE NEVER SAID
ANYTHING NEGATIVE AND LESS THEY
GOT OKAY FROM CONDE NAST, UNLESS
THEY GOT THE OKAY FROM ANNA.
THEY WOULD'VE NEVER GOT THE OKAY
TO COMMENT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SPECIFICALLY.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ATTACKING YOU FOR YOUR
T-SHIRT.
>> IT WAS A SETUP.
IT STARTED OFF AS -- IT STARTED
OFF AS THEM HAVING THIS BLACK
GIRL COMMENT AND TO SAY I FELT
TRAUMATIZED WHEN I SAW THIS
T-SHIRT.
A BLACK GIRL SAYING I FELT
TRAUMATIZED WHEN I SAW A BLACK
MAN WEARING SOMETHING HE WASN'T
ALLOWED TO WEAR.
IT'S LIKE IN DJANGO WAS ON TOP
OF THE HORSE AND SAMUEL JACKSON
SAYS HE'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE ON
TOP OF THE HORSE.
I SAID I DON'T LIKE YOUR BOOTS.
YOU'RE NOT A FASHION PERSON.
AND THEN PEOPLE STARTED TO SAY I
WAS A BULLY.
IT WAS A SET UP AND THEY FINALLY
GOT HIT BECAUSE I ELIMINATED THE
BLM OFFICER.
AND THEN I GOT OUT OF THE GAP
DEAL AND ONE BY ONE BY ONE, I
HAVE BEEN WINNING THESE BATTLES.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD ME.
THEY HAD THE IDEA THAT YE WAS
BULLYING -- WHAT I THINK THE
LIBERAL TERM IS A BODY GOALS
BLACK WOMAN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT GABBY AND MY
GOOD FRIEND LIZZO.
SHE WORKS WITH MY TRAINER, WHEN
SHE LOSES 10 POUNDS AND
ANNOUNCES IT, THE BOTS -- THAT'S
A TERM FOR, TELEMARKETER COLLARS
ON INSTAGRAM ATTACKER FOR LOSING
WEIGHT BECAUSE THE MEDIA WANTS
TO PUT OUT A PERCEPTION THAT
BEING OVERWEIGHT IS THE NEW GOAL
WHEN IT'S ACTUALLY UNHEALTHY.
ASIDE FROM THE FACT WHETHER IT'S
FASHION AND VOGUE, OR IF SOMEONE
THINKS IT'S ATTRACTIVE, TO EACH
HIS OWN.
IT'S ACTUALLY CLINICALLY
UNHEALTHY.
FOR PEOPLE TO PROMOTE THAT, IT'S
DEMONIC.
>> Tucker: I'VE NOTICED THIS
ALSO, WHY DO YOU THINK THEY
WOULD WANT TO PROMOTE UNHEALTHY
NESTS AMONG THE POPULATION?
>> ITS OF THE BLACK RACE.
THEY WANT TO KILL US IN ANY WAY
THEY CAN.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WAS MADE BY
MARGARET SANGER WITH THE KKK AND
I BELIEVE THAT IF WE SAW
OURSELVES AS -- IF WE SAW
OURSELVES AS A PEOPLE AND NOT A
RACE, THEN WE WOULD TREAT OUR
PEOPLE BETTER.
IF YOU GO TO A JEWISH PERSON AND
SAY A RACE IT ALMOST GETS
CONFUSING, THEY WILL CUT YOU OFF
QUICKLY AND SAY WE ARE NOT A
RACE, WE ARE PEOPLE.
OUR PEOPLE ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO
SAY SAY IT LOUD I'M BLACK AND
I'M PROUD -- WHAT ABOUT, DO YOU
OWN THE LAND YOU'RE LIVING IN?
DO YOU OWN -- IS THE CONTRACT IN
A LANGUAGE THAT'S POSSIBLY
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR YOUR
HERITAGE?
IN AMERICA WE WILL DOWN EACH
OTHER ON HOW GOOD WE SPEAK BUT
WE ARE SPEAKING ENGLISH.
THERE'S NOTHING WHITER THAN
ENGLISH, WE ARE NOT IN OUR
NATIVE TONGUE ACTUALLY.
WE JUDGE EACH OTHER ON WHI